we've been following the approval rating
of Donald Trump for some time it's
relevant for a number of reasons which
I've told you about and will tell you
about again and we've seen Trump's
approval rating sporadically in the
low-30s in a variety of different polls
but not in the Gallup daily presidential
approval tracking poll that's sort of
the gold standard for comparison for
presidential approval gallops daily
tracking poll has been around for
decades and Trump's previous low in that
poll was 35 percent and as you'll see
here if you're watching with us on this
graph that we put up on the screen on
three days three different days during
August August 13th 23rd and 24th Donald
Trump's approval rating hit yet another
presidency low of 34 percent now as of
this morning it was back to 35 percent
but what I want to call your attention
to in this graph is that if we analyze
this graph like we might analyze a stock
price of a company that's publicly
traded we'd see that despite the fact
that the low hasn't dropped that much
the low the the the presidency low had
been 36% for a while and then we saw 35%
and then now we saw 34% you can look at
the trend line and see that the general
trend is going lower and lower Trump's
high points are lower and lower and
we're picking up lower and lower low
points as well now there's some other
internals from Trump's approval that I
want to briefly mention 16% of Americans
like Donald Trump's conduct as president
of the United States that's according to
a Pew Research poll that's a separate
question from approval you can dislike
Trump's conduct but still approve of the
job that he's doing requires a little
bit of cognitive dissonance but there's
plenty of that to go around among Trump
supporters and also from the Gallup
daily tracking poll internals with young
people meaning 18 to 29 year olds 20
percent approval 20 percent approval 80
percent of individuals age 18 to 29
either disapprove of the trut job Trump
is doing or aren't sure this is
indicative
of trouble for 20/20 because you are
going to have more voters who will have
turned 18 between last election day and
the next one and they presumably are not
going to be friendly to Donald Trump
however I want to be very upfront and
clear about something with you
despite Donald Trump's unpopularity even
at 34 35 % he could still win reelection
sure in 2020 and the math is actually
quite it's it's almost so simple that
many people are missing it there's an
article in the week from Damon linker
and it points out pretty astutely pretty
obviously as well that just because you
don't a proof of Donald Trump doesn't
mean that number one you'll vote at all
number one you might just not vote even
though you disapprove of the job Trump
is doing you might not vote because you
don't think your vote makes a difference
or just you don't really vote and number
two it doesn't mean that you would
necessarily vote for someone else you
could be a Republican who disapproves of
the job that Donald Trump is doing but
you're not gonna vote for whoever the
next Hillary Clinton is or Bernie
Sanders or whoever it is that ultimately
runs in 2020 and this comes down to
election polls versus approval polls for
election prediction polls and we've
talked about this you need a likely
voter model because if you're trying to
predict an election we don't have
mandatory voting in the u.s. you need to
assess who is going to vote and only
among those people who are they likely
to vote for approval polls are just do
you approve of the job Trump is doing as
president regardless of whether you did
vote or plan to vote and that's where we
get to the simple math of it Trump won
the 2016 election with 46 point four
percent of the popular vote he lost the
popular vote eked out small wins in
three key states and ultimately defeated
Hillary Clinton in the electoral college
voter turnout was about 50%
this means that Trump only needed
roughly 25 percent of the vote of all
eligible American voters because turnout
was so low this means that if 34 percent
of the country approves of Donald Trump
you can still win because Trump won with
only 25 percent of the eligible votes
seems like if he's done it once he can
do it again absolute Michael Moore who's
one of the few progressive voices who
predicted that Donald Trump was going to
win the 2016 election yeah
now predicts that he's going to win
re-election maybe he'll lose by even
more in the popular vote but he still
could hold on to those states that like
Michigan and Pennsylvania and Wisconsin
because it's just his message is
resonating there and that's why we have
to either try to push for eliminating
the electoral college or just pushing
for something easier which is a national
interstate popular vote compact we've
talked about that that would be where if
enough states that if enough states
whose total electoral vote electoral
vote count comprises 270 they can pledge
to put their electoral votes towards the
winner of the popular vote nationally
and that is de-facto
eliminating the electoral vote but we
will dig into that more on a future
program the video you just watched was
made possible by support from you please
go to patreon.com slash david pakman
show you can make a pledge of as little
as one dollar per month and every dollar
helps to support the work that we're
doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad